with the budding rumor that samsung has
created phones like the galaxy flip z
and galaxy z fold 2 both of which
feature a foldable design that
transfigures from one shape to another
it is only natural that technology
giants like apple
would follow suit however one is left to
wonder if apple has given
any thought and mapped out plans for
this trend in innovation
before we get started with this video
don't forget to subscribe to our youtube
channel
and click on the bell button for
notifications on our new uploads
so talking about apple's next big
invention there is no doubt that
affordable iphone would be topping the
list
in this video we will discuss apple inc
as a company
the idea behind iphone designs the
vision of making iphones foldable
and what these foldable phones may look
like stay with us
and we will be revealing some really
amazing secrets about apple's
next big invention let's get started
shall we clues of a foldable iphone
kicked off in 2016
when reports allegedly unveiled the lg
display would be mass producing foldable
exhibitions
for smartphones in 2018. the rumor
claimed that lg would be supplying these
foldable devices to companies like
google and apple
a 2017 rumor kept the folding iphone
idea alive
specifying that apple would go into some
sort of partnership with lg to develop
an iphone with a foldable feature
no doubt lg has over the years proven
its ability to come up with innovative
foldable display prototypes
that use flexible oled panels amongst
these prototypes
are the one that folds over like a book
and another that rolls up like a
newspaper
just recently samsung offered to supply
foldable prototypes to apple
for use in future iphones some other
reports have on good record
that corning an apple supplier is
consistently working on a foldable glass
solution
and since workable ideas were
consistently coming up apple went on to
create patents for these ideas
just so we don't get too excited it has
been on record that apple patents all
kinds of things
that never got to the launch stage so
patents are not necessarily a dependable
way to forecast
what's in development apple was
definitely not letting any opportunity
slide as they made their very first
foldable iphone patent come alive in
2016.
no doubt samsung gave us a clue on what
a foldable phone would look like
a screen folding vertically and
momentarily shutting off
however leave it to apple to revamp that
idea and create an amazing design out of
it
and for apple recounting the phone that
folds horizontally in half using a
flexible oled screen
and a hinged metal support assembly was
just the ideal invention
amazingly both halves of the screen
remain accessible
even with the phone shut was apple going
to stop at a horizontally foldable phone
with an amazing flexible oled
screen and hinge metal support
absolutely not
three years later apple has thoughts of
incorporating a heating element into the
fold
a 2019 apple's patent application
presented a foldable smartphone with a
built-in heating element
the idea behind the heating element was
to cut down on failures at the fold
in cold temperatures which can impact
foldable smartphones terribly okay
so now there is a horizontally foldable
iphone patent with a heating element
but wait a minute something was still
missing how about
a foldable iphone with a hinge metal
support that makes use of
movable flaps in february 2020 apple
licensed a patent for a foldable device
with a hinge mechanism that uses movable
flaps to help prevent the screen from
getting damaged
when folded the hinge device is designed
solely with the aim of ensuring passable
separations between
the first and second parts of the screen
when the device is
unfolded these movable flaps spread to
cover the gap
and then pulls back when the device is
folded naturally
we would think the thinking part is done
and apple would at least get down to
creating prototypes at this stage
but there was just one more thing to
improve on
a month after the last patent was
released apple released yet another
patent to display a distinctive
alternative to a foldable iphone
they even went on to present an
incredible idea of a system allowing two
or more devices to act as one
when brought close to each other via the
use of proximity sensors
the patent also envisions two separate
devices that would spontaneously detect
themselves when placed together with a
shared screen
nonetheless leaker john prosser claims
that apple
is also working on a foldable iphone
prototype that vaunts two separate
display panels connected by a hinge
this would be something new since the
samsung galaxy fold has a single display
design
having a foldable phone is one thing but
having one that has
all the features that apple plans will
be straight out crazy
from the look of things apple may have
decided on what they want their foldable
iphone to look like
and feature apple in november 2020
purportedly begun sending foldable
iphones to foxconn for testing purposes
the testing includes evaluating the use
of micro led or oled
as well as the use of bearings as the
foldable part of the device
apparently apple was testing more than
one prototype of the foldable designs at
the foxconn factory in shenzhen china
it won't be shocking if apple decides to
toss in some more designs in the long
run
big technology giants like apple take
their time in launching new products in
the market
probably because they would like to keep
their reputation and name intact
one of the proposed foldable iphones
would have round stainless steel edges
like the iphone 11
and in place of the notch apple has
included a tiny forehead that houses
face id
even with the prototype being two
separate panels the display would still
look fairly continuous and seamless
the other suggested prototype is a
foldable iphone with a clamshell design
similar to the samsung galaxy z flip
with apple testing
so many prototype designs there is no
clear indication
if this present prototype or any
prototype will make it to the eventual
launch
in december 2020 nevertheless another
rumor from the asian supply chain
revealed that two of apple's foldable
iphone prototypes
made it through internal testing for
durability that's big news for apple
devotees
something is in the pipeline at least so
having such a great phone but still
moving around with the fear that the
screen would eventually get cracked
won't be a great feeling trust me but
hey
apple is one step ahead on that problem
a 2020 patent filing proposes that apple
was also looking at getting a protective
layer for their foldable iphone
this would in turn help the iphones
resist cracking the iphone would also
flaunt a hard coat layer that would
naturally fill pre-existing micro cracks
to make it harder for a larger crack to
surface the extra layer would be
positioned directly on top of the screen
and would resist scratches and punctures
it seems we are not the only ones
anticipating apple's next big invention
a note from the bank of america merrill
lynch analyst in 2018
recommended a foldable iphone would
surface in 2020
but that didn't happen another rumor in
november 2020 from the chinese supply
chain claimed that apple aims for a 2022
release date
for a foldable iphone there is no word
on the actual form apple's foldable
iphone might really take
since there are no tangible rumors about
a foldable iphone on the line of launch
there is no doubt that a foldable phone
would make a lot of sense
however with the introduction of the
samsung foldable phones into the market
many reviewers provided with one of the
new devices exposed major durability
issues of the screens breaking after
just a few days of
use aside from this there is yet another
case of at least
one user having issues with the phone
screen cracking and cold temperatures
nonetheless if this foldable apple
device becomes a reality
the next question that would be on
everyone's lips would be
how much would this device go for this
is
easily the hardest question to answer
since the price has never been a factor
for the few foldable iphones already in
existence
also the device's cost will mostly
depend on how apple goes about its
design
now considering that the galaxy full
debuted for almost two thousand dollars
with a 7.3 inch tablet-like display when
unfolded
and a rather tiny 4.6 inch panel on the
outside
six months later the galaxy z flip was
launched with a more vertically
proportioned 6.7 inch screen covered in
ultra thin glass for better durability
and was sold for 600
less the price of apple's foldable
iphone has no clear prediction pinned on
it
if apple decides to go for the cheaper
and smaller foldable
the phone's price may have the same
price as premium handsets like the
iphone 11 pro max
nonetheless if the foldable iphone is
projected as a phone that can become a
tablet when the need arises
like the galaxy fold it most certainly
would come with a price higher than
apple's other more conventional
smartphones
anyway while we didn't get an iphone 12
flip last year
and with the trending rumors that the
iphone 13 flip may never see the light
of day
there is no doubt apple is getting more
involved with flexible displays
this simply means that they would
eventually release a handset or two that
would be foldable
of course the question remains when this
is a possibility
since their latest project is rumored to
be launched toward the end of 2021
one thing we know for certain is by the
time apple releases a foldable phone
you can be sure the technology will be
more time-honored than it is today
as reference examples we have seen
foldable smartphones that fold
vertically both
outwards and inwards from huawei and
samsung
apple's patents have featured a device
that folds horizontally and is not
really as wide as samsung and huawei's
smartphone versions
but apple's patents are more theoretical
that's it for me today on apple's next
big invention what do you think about
this next big move
apple is planning to take do you think
it will see the light of day
share your thoughts in the comment
section below if this video was
insightful
don't forget to like the video please go
and subscribe to our youtube channel
and don't forget to click the bell
button to be notified whenever we upload
videos like this one
that's it for me guys don't forget to
stay safe and
i will see you in the next video